at this moment we have not able to
confirm successful landing on the lunar
surface it's not the outcome Japanese
firm ispace was hoping for it wanted to
be the first private company to complete
a successful lunar Landing but despite
the setback ispace is optimistic
the journey began in December with
SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket blasted off in
Cape Canaveral in Florida carrying a
Lander called the M1 Vehicles it's taken
five months for the craft to get into
position the M1 Lander traveled around
1.5 million kilometers away from Earth
before looping back towards the moon
this longer slower route saved on fuel
allowed it to carry more cargo
one of the items on board is a small
Rover from the United Arab Emirates long
term companies are hoping to turn these
Moon missions into business
opportunities there's a few different
incentives for companies to land on the
moon some of it is mining access there
are some valuable minerals on the moon
that companies would really like to
exploit some companies want to get there
for defense purposes kind of in
preparation for maybe humans expanding
to the moon and then some companies have
at least a little bit of a scientific
exploration aspect to it they want to
learn more about the moon that's
generally something though where the
funding is coming from a government
agency working with these companies
rather than a company
kind of proactively deciding they would
like to explore the moon for scientific
purposes it has been working tirelessly
to get ready for this day i-space says
this is just the beginning it's planning
more missions to the Moon one as early
as next year and utilizing other
companies are also likely to accelerate
their efforts as lunar surface looks set
to become the new frontier
Finton Monahan Al Jazeera